hello everyone and welcome to a really
spectacular game from round two of the
fiji world cup that's currently being
played in russia it's daniel dubo versus
vladimir malakov and it's
really a game that will um that will
make you want to play
chess right away after you see it it's
uh it's a work of art
actually and um a lot of time when we
have duba playing
he will create these positions that are
simply impossible to analyze like
this video uh there will be no positive
video moment because
every position here the like any move
can be a positive video moment but
you'll see
uh what i mean by this and i've taken
only a handful of variations that i
thought were
really really exciting and that you
might enjoy and we're gonna
explore uh some of them so this game
it's really like
um it's hard to put words to it it's
like listening to maybe
bach music performed very well while
being baited in
i don't know maybe some rosemary and
lemonade some maybe peppermint or i
don't know but it's it's like that
so without further ado let's check it
out uh and see what
this is all about so uh daniel with the
white pieces opens with
d4 uh we have d5 by molecule c4 we have
c6
going for the slav defense knight to f3
knight to f6
and knight to c3 uh and here we have a6
also known as the chameleon variation we
have g3 now do both prepares the fiance
of his light square bishop
and d captures on c4 so this is all very
standard at some point
black might may or may not play
something like b5 to try and uh
solidify his position on the queen side
but that never really works out as
intended we have bishop to g2
g6 now black also wants to fianchetto
his bishop and now we have castles
bishop to g7
and e4 now grabbing more space in the
center we have castles by black
uh and now there is a game in the
database where white played a4 i mean
who wouldn't you want to challenge
black's idea of playing b5 but here
dubois ignores this and here he plays
queen to e2 making it that already as of
move 9 we have a completely new game
so black of course takes this
opportunity to advance his pawn to b5
now defending his c4 pawn and only now
uh dublin advances his pawn uh on a4 not
to prevent b5 but rather to challenge b5
so black advances is pawn to b4 attacks
dubose knight here and
now knight back to d1 but now uh the c4
pawn is under attack and that there is
no good way of defending this
pawn so here we have a5 now defending
the
the b4 pawn and really just making room
for his bishop on a6 so indirectly you
are defending it so if you capture now
bishop to a6 will just win the exchange
so instead rook to e1 first now getting
ready to pick up the pawn here and now
uh
sorry uh rook to e1 and now uh a5
uh so sorry and now bishop to a6 as
planned so now the pawn is very well
defended here
but now we have e5 just attacking this
pawn
uh attacking the knight and now what do
you do here well there's a
uh question do you go here or do you uh
advance the pawn to c3 just attacking
the queen and it's a very
interesting line for example if c3 we
can move the queen
now see capture some b2 bishop captures
and now play knight to d5 but
uh it's almost as if you've helped white
to develop instead of
maybe hindered his development uh you
can go e6 right away you can bring the
rook to c1 it's a
it's a very nice position for white so
after this e5 black plays knight to d5
right away
and here e6 now asking black what do you
want to do here
so you definitely don't want to question
uh capture here the question is whether
you want to advance the pawn to f6 or
all the way to f5 black advance is it
all the way to f5
and now knight to e5 so it's a very
uh tricky knight you never want to
capture this because your dark square
bishop is basically half of your
defenses here
so here rook to f6 now getting ready for
knight
to f7 so the rook will be ready here and
you want to challenge this pawn so rook
will come here queen can come here
we can maybe attack it again maybe we
can play knight c7 pile up on this pawn
because we really want to get rid of
this pawn
and uh while white could capture on c4
it's uh definitely an option dubo
doesn't bother himself with this he just
goes knight to f7
so he attacks the queen queen to c8 now
also black is attacking this pawn twice
but it's also
uh defended twice so it's not a problem
and now duboff could uh
you know try to play this in in a
variety of ways he could go bishop to h6
he could go knight to h6 check
but he plays a move that uh well a lot
of people would not even consider and
that's uh
this is where the fun really starts he
plays knight to e3
and now his uh queen and rook are no
longer guarding this spawn and he
challenges
black to capture it are you gonna
capture this pawn and
black says all right i don't really have
any other options uh i
i will have to capture this pawn out
there's a double attack here on d5 if i
allow this captures
not that but if i allow captures
captures and bishop captures could be
could be problematic for me so black
accepts the challenge he plays rook
captures on e6 and
now uh well now comes knight the g5
attacking the rook and asking what do
you want to play here so
bringing the rook back to f6 doesn't
really work because we already said
knight captures and bishop captures will
win the rook here on a8 so that's out of
the question
one thing you could do is play rook to
d6 but this is also
uh dead loss for black and it's just
amazing at
what would happen here so most of the uh
you know
these ideas that we'll explore in this
game never actually happened over the
board
but such is the case with every great
game so knight captures on the 5c
captures now queen captures an e7
attacking the rook here
uh if the rook moves of course bishop
captures and e5 we also have access to
this square
but another thing we're threatening for
example if queen d7 just defends the
rook we're threatening queen e8 to check
the knight covers f7
so this is a huge problem for black for
example captures captures you have to
block with bishop to f8
only move and now bishop to f4 and now
the bishop
pair is uh definitely fully operational
let's say the rook moves you kind of
have to keep an eye on this pawn
but now knight to e6 and now there's a
double attack on the bishop here and now
the only way to defend
is to block well is to help out with the
defense of the bishop but now we simply
capture knight captures rook captures
rook captures
or we don't even have to capture with
the rook we can first play bishop
captures on d5 to make sure we grab this
one
and now it's all over uh you could even
run into king h8 bishop to e5 checkmate
so there's even that on the board
so after knight to g5 black decides that
okay maybe rook to d6 isn't the right
course of action
i could capture here i've already
grabbed the pawn so i might as well give
up the exchange
but here black decides for c3 and it's
uh it's a move that will be played at
some point so
you might as well play it right away so
queen to c2
and now again uh what do you play uh the
rook is still under attack so
you could move the rook then we play
queen to b3
now the knight cannot move as the king
is here and you might play e6 so this is
a position that
uh could occur over the board and then
white just uh you know
continues in in in a lot of ways you can
capture here you can bring the knight to
c4
for the harass the rook it's a it's a
game that black could play
but it's a it's a game that black chose
not to play so instead after queen to c2
we have rook captures on e3 black said
all right i did grab a point i'm gonna
give back uh some material so
he sacrifices the exchange bishop
captures an e3 and now
c captures on b2 we have queen captures
on b2 by double
uh and now knight to d7 so black really
starts
needs to start developing his pieces we
have rook 8 to c1 and now
knight comes to b6 so what do you do
here your a4 pawn is under attack we
have queen to b3 defending the pawn
and also not allowing the knight to move
so here bush back to b7
adding uh well another defender here and
bishop to f4 now and now this bishop is
uh
well slowly but surely becoming a a
monster as the knight cannot capture it
we have bishop to f6 now making sure
that if the bishop ever moves anywhere
you will
lose the knight here but now knight the
e6
and again what can black play well you
can't really capture it even though
there are two pieces now in front of the
black king on this diagonal if you go
for something like knight captures on f4
then just g
captures on f4 and this is uh simply
unplayable there is not
much you can do here for example king
h82 and pin d5 is coming and it's just
too too ugly to to even look at so
instead after knight to e6 we have king
to h8 black
uh gets away from this um this diagonal
so now the knight can move
but now bishop to h6 of course you don't
allow
black to capture this bishop and now you
have full control of the g7 square for
example
so this bishop for the moment is stuck
on f6 and the problem here is that
black really has no move there's no move
you can play for black
and that's uh i mean it's just an ugly
position so here black plays
queen to g8 now he puts the queen on
this diagonal
but it doesn't really help here white
just plays h4 he wants to play h5
and further weaken black's king side
because there is no move for black
uh if you tried to find an active move
there there would be
none there there's no good square for
the rook the queen can't really do
anything
and the one active move that you might
think you have knights the c3 just
falls to rook captures on c3 captures
and you lose a knight here so two pieces
for the rook and your your position is
just ugly
there's uh there's nothing to play here
so here black played rook to b8
sort of a waiting move and now duo uh
increases the activity of his rooks rook
the c5
now attacking the a5 pawn as the rook is
no longer defending it
so black brings the rook back rook to a8
and now knight to g5
so asking uh do you do maybe you want to
capture this i mean it's a move you can
play
uh but like i said this bishop is really
the the only good defender of
black's king's side and now you're
asking okay my knight moved from
e6 no longer defending the d4 pawn do
maybe we want to capture on d4
but this just falls apart uh incredibly
if bishop captures on d4 we give up the
rook on c5 we just play rook captures on
e7
and now how do you defend the rook
captures on h7 well
one thing is you could capture the rook
but even that will not help you if you
capture the knight
then knight to f7 check and you have to
give up your queen
queen captures queen captures and now
okay uh you might capture the rook but
if you capture the rook you're getting
checkmated bishop captures queen
delivers checkmate and if you don't
uh well you're just down a queen with no
compensation whatsoever
so after knight the g5 we have rooked to
a7
now preparing to move the bishop maybe
the rook will help out with the defense
of the seventh rank
uh and now rook back to c2 now double
will double rooks and the e
file we have queen to e8 queen to e8
uh you have to kind of bring the queen
to help out with the defense here
so queen to e8 but you also just need a
move but now rook to e6
so again with terrible terrible threats
here
uh there's not not much for black for
black to do here queen to d7 is a nice
waiting move
but black decides that now is the time
to capture the pawn
so bishop captures on d4 but now dubuque
just says
this still is not a problem h5 he just
continues with his plan let's attack the
king's side
bishop goes back to f6 it kind of helps
out with the defense of the g6 square
and also still guards the e7 uh pawn so
it's a
it's a nice defender we have rook c to
e2 now do both doubles up on the e file
and again uh there's there's no move
here black and play for example if you
play some like rook to a8
uh we just give up the rook here rook
captures the bishop and now after let's
say knight captures we play queen to e6
you could also play
just knight f7 check that also wins but
queen to e6
is just game over there's uh there's
nothing to be
played here and it's uh well just
terrible
you could even run into some like bishop
the c8 and queen captures here and
you're you're still getting checkmated
so that's kind of the idea of queen to
e6 completely stifling black's position
but
the real thread is always knight to f7
check and there's no defense against
this
so after rook c to e2 we have bishop
captures on g5 now black is
black has to play something and this
knight is uh you know is a menace here
uh on g5 so bishop captures and now not
capturing right away but first queen to
be
to check which allows black to finally
move this knight and
block check and now how are you ever
getting rid of this knight well that's
the beauty of this game
you don't have to the queen will remain
here for
for for quite a long time so bishop
captures on g5 and now
what do you play knight captures on a4
so you attack the queen once again
but the dubo just plays the com queen to
a1 still
not allowing this knight to move and
asking black how are you defending this
this is attacked three times
is there anything you can do here so
here king the g8 getting
off of this diagonal so now knight
captures rook is a threat
so double just moves it rook to e1 and
again black is without a move we have
bishop to a6 now trying to activate also
the rook is now helping out with the
defense here but still it's attacked
three times not a lot black can do about
this
and here we have bishop captures on c6
just attacking the queen
queen to d8 and now bishop captures on
a4 so just grabbing material there's
nothing black can do
and even if you capture here white will
not capture back necessarily white can
play queen to e5 and it's a dead lost
position for black
for example bishop c8 you could attack
something but just h6 we threaten
checkmate now
and if black defense for example bishop
captures an a7 that's that's game over
queen f7
rook to f6 now for example queen e8 and
now we can play bishop captures and
before even
uh even ideas like uh these are in the
position and now there's no defense you
are you are threatening pretty much
everything here and of course if
captures uh then a nice rook to f8 will
be checkmate as the pawn covers the g7
square
so after bishop captures on a4 uh we
have queen to d5 now
uh by malakov and now comes uh bishop to
c6 and he was in this position on move
after the time control has been reached
that duboff
created this masterpiece and well black
black resigned as there is simply
nothing more to be done here
so an incredible game and um well it's
often that uh you will see games like
this but very often
they come from duboff uh because you
know there's uh
the it's like the the old stan lee
quoted that they keep
you know repeating with great power
comes great responsibility here dubo has
the great power to create such
games but he also takes you know his
responsibility very seriously
so we can all be thankful for this and
we you know we we can only hope it
continues for a very
long long time so we can enjoy uh
masterpieces like
like this uh this one here so yeah uh
outstanding game and here you resign
because you're down material and there's
really nothing you can do if you move
the queen you you can't move the queen
to a dark square
for example queen here then just bishop
here we you lose the rook as well if you
move the queen somewhere like queen to
d8 it doesn't really matter we can just
pick up
d7 pawn we can always do this it doesn't
really matter when we do it
now let's say queen d2 but now we can
play bishop to c5
attack the rook and now our bishop pair
will become fully operational
let's say bishop c4 goes after the rook
we're going to play rookie to check
and after king moves we can play bishop
captures on b4 so even this
is in the position you can't capture
because the rook falls uh if you do
nothing then the knight will fall
because
you've just eliminated the pawn that
defends it so it's you know
there's nothing to be done here so i
hope you agree with me that
when i decided not to make any positive
video moments here because
every moment in this game could be a
positive video moment so i thought we
best
we'd best just enjoy it and uh you know
i i've tried to explore some of the more
interesting lines and i've chosen
uh those that were you know kind of
flashy because i know you guys enjoy
those but
uh this game you know the to be fully
analyzed i i think you'd you require a
few hours and
you could even make a series you know a
netflix series about this game you know
just you know in in eight parts for
example
uh but yeah enough being said i i really
hope you guys enjoyed this one
when i when i saw the final position i
was like yeah it's a fun position but
then when i saw the game i was like
yeah that that's that's the good stuff
so yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it
impeccable stuff by by double we'll see
what happens in game two if malcolm
will be able to bounce back or will do
both uh go uh further
into the the fiji world cup uh so yeah
i would like to thank tom daralao vivek
patka deepak madapa
michael mooney and kim longu for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day